good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is scp-1506
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
high resolution satellite imagery is to
be processed by computer for possible
scp-1506-1
occurrences once confirmed as an
occurrence
scp-1506-1's position is to be monitored
and checked against computer modeling of
wind patterns should
scp-1506-1 rapidly descend or ascend
into a wind current predicted to take
scp-1506-1
through human-populated areas mobile
task force phi 17 the arachnophobes are
to be readied for procedures 1506 a b
and c
procedure 1506 a
using mobile anti-smog fans mobile task
force 517 are to attempt to guide
scp-1506-1
into a wind current predicted to take
scp-1506-1
towards a local nature reserve populated
with larger mammalia if necessary to
disguise the procedure from the public
cover will be provided as cutting edge
industrial agriculture testing in rural
areas and as air quality specialists in
urban areas
procedure 1506 b
should 1506 a fail to keep
scp-1506-1 away from human population
centers mobile task force 517 are to
begin type b amnestic treatment as
necessary for witnesses of predation
procedure 1506 c
mobile task force 517 are to use mobile
stasis locks to contain the area around
scp-1506-1
while flamethrowers and arachnocyte 7
are used to disperse scp-1506-1
arachnocyte 7's boiling point is above
1500 degrees celsius making it safe to
use with conventional flamethrowers
under no circumstances may arachnocyte-7
be used without stasis locks active to
contain the aftermath arachnocyte-7 must
not be allowed to enter the biosphere
procedure 1506 d
following incident 1506 sigma any
instance of
scp-1506-1 larger than 200 cubic meters
in commercial flight paths are cleared
for immediate barometric implosion using
fae detonation contained via mobile
stasis lock
scp-1506-1114 is contained at site-9 in
a pressure-controlled large animal
containment cell atmospheric pressure is
to be maintained to keep scp-1506-114
approximately in the center of the
containment cell when
scp-1506-114 descends to an artificial
altitude of less than 500 meters viable
prey animals are to be introduced to the
cell it has been calculated that
kilograms of food over a four week
period will help keep the colony at its
current size in the event of containment
breach arachnocyte 7 will be deployed in
combination with increasing containment
cell pressure to atmospheres arachnocyte
7 must not be allowed to enter the
biosphere
the following are outdated containment
procedures
scp-1506 is position is to be monitored
and checked against computer modeling of
wind patterns should scp-1506 rapidly
descend or ascend into a wind current
predicted to take scp-1506 through
human-populated areas mobile task force
phi 7 are to be readied for procedures
1506 a
and b
description
scp-1506 is the designation for the
global phenomenon which spontaneously
generates instances of scp-1506-1
scp-1506-1 is the designation for
anomalous colonies of at least
approximately 900 spiders of mixed
species by application of multiple
varieties of spider silk
scp-1506-1 is able to build complex web
structure less dense than air in which
the spiders may live
scp-1506-1 exhibits remarkable behavior
as individual spiders are rarely seen
working in cooperation and never in
cross-species cooperation scp-1506-1
also shows changes in predation behavior
web tension strength and web adhesion
scp-1506-1 has been found at altitudes
of up to 18 kilometers in order to
change altitude the volume of
scp-1506-1 is increased or decreased
suggesting the web structure is being
consistently maintained
when
scp-1506-1 descends below 500 meters it
is to be assumed that the colony will
soon begin predation behavior thus far
it is unknown how spiders are able to
detect their prey at this height
scp-1506-1's preferred method of
predation is to spin a web to the ground
from altitude any animalia touching the
spider web will instantly adhere and be
unable to remove the web only live
animal matter exhibits this effect when
enough food has been caught
scp-1506-1 will reel in the web at
kilometers per hour when
scp-1506-1 has fully reeled in its prey
the web structure will engulf the animal
consumption of prey takes place over
days dependent on both the signs of the
prey and the colony humans take
approximately five days for an average
sized colony to digest the largest
single prey animal recorded has been an
elk taking 11 days to digest waste is
allowed to fall freely leaving a
desiccated husk that will often shatter
on impact
scp-1506-1 was first identified as
scp-1506
before the realization of multiple
instances
scp-1506-1 was first brought to the
foundation's attention on
2000
when a viral video thought to originate
in chile showed a man walking through
the streets of
at o2 47 local time according to the
timestamps for two minutes he is tracked
by eight security cameras the footage of
which has been seamlessly edited
together until he suddenly stops walking
whilst looking very startled the subject
of the video begins brushing at his arms
and face before vanishing high-speed
analysis shows that he had been dragged
vertically out of the frame the poor
resolution of the security footage has
made it impossible to determine the
actual speed but kilometers per hour is
within estimations the footage has been
doctored to remove the three frames and
has been publicly revealed to be part of
the viral campaign for
energy drink
scp-1506-114 is a colony captured on
2000
cameras placed on prey animals have
shown internal structure to be
incredibly complex the colony is divided
into living chambers and buoyancy
chambers with no genus of spider
noticeably more active in web
maintenance every foreign spider
introduced to the colony has been
accepted without incident introducing
new spider species to scp-1506-114
is now banned 200 different spiders from
around the world have been introduced to
the colony and it is believed that there
is no more data to be gained from this
research
scp-1506-114 is being studied to
determine longevity of the colony so far
the colony remains healthy in a
simulated high altitude environment
feeding when necessary
using remote cameras to explore the
structure has proven a failure as all
attempts have had the drone immobilized
by web and excreted in the usual manner
spider mounted cameras have failed in a
similar manner the only successful
method to obtain internal visuals is
through prey mounted camera which allows
only for stationary video feeds tests
indicate a normal oxygen and atmospheric
pressure level within the living
chambers
little headway has been made as to the
mode of transmission of scp-1506
but the most favored theory is
communication of learned behavior
investigation is ongoing into how the
spiders communicate research on the
malos gregolas and other social spiders
has been promising but so far no headway
has been made so far
scp-1506-1 has appeared on all
continents except antarctica and shows
no preference for member spider species
either solitary or social
addendum event 1501 alpha playing log
now
i think it's trying to pretend it's a
weather balloon but weather balloons
don't float this low
great
we found the killer low-flying weather
balloon
i guess we could pop it they're called
special containment procedures
not
[Music]
it would save time though i'm going in
for a closer look style shop
three minutes 42 seconds of radio
silence as agent r approaches location
i've got visual on the binoculars i can
see it pulsing
it looks like it's made out of
fabric what do you think giant
lasso i don't think we're bringing this
one in ourselves
we're gonna need nerds
right that'd be like that they're why we
have jobs
not them
i stepped in a spider web
agent oz radio device transmits a 16
second scream followed by heavy
breathing and sobbing
oh god they're crawling on me i
can't move
god's so hot oh god
agent r was in radio contact for a
further 18 hours and seven minutes
during this time agent r was unable to
provide more useful information on the
nature of scp-1506
event 1506 sigma on 2000
scp-150619
collided with commercial flight
scp-150619 had been under special
observation due to its significant
volume it has been theorized that
scp-150619 contained over 2 million
individual spiders on impact with flight
scp-150619 was observed to burst the web
structure was observed to cling to the
plane for 40 seconds before being pulled
into a damaged seam between fuselage
panels the black box flight recorder
indicates these spiders entered the
flight cabin causing significant damage
to the aircraft's electronics including
radio equipment the flight continued for
another 78 minutes before crashing the
following is an excerpt from the
recording
playing log now
what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] i don't know
give me the [ __ ] mic
this is
your co-pilot for today we do apologize
for the flight turbulence back there we
do our best to make your flight as
smooth as possible but the occasional
hiccup will happen we thank you for your
understanding and remember to keep
flying with airlines
okay what the [ __ ] happened i thought it
was a cloud all right clouds don't make
a bang when you hit him i meant to be on
break seriously
what is wrong with you don't
don't tell me you thought it was
anything other than cloud cover you were
looking i was meant to take a nap in
half an hour and now my heart's racing
thanks for that well piss off then
metallic banging can be heard assumed to
be flight attendant
at the cockpit door
[Music]
i just want a nap jesus what did i do
what is it
use the phone
banging continues
i'll have a look oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what may day mayday this is flight in
immediate distress require urgent
assistant on spider infestation over
what the [ __ ] can they get through the
door this is insane this is flight
our flight cabin has been compromised by
spiders and they're [ __ ] everywhere
someone [ __ ] come in over pan pan
mayday anyone
recording skips 60 minutes for full
audio files c150619bb.mp3
hey lauren's okay
rudder okay
elevator's okay radio
[ __ ] well at least we're not dead
stick
30 seconds of silence
we agreed this is what we have to do
i don't want to die
neither do i
neither do
if we're doing this it has to be now
we're getting too close to i hope it's
fast we'll be the first to hit the plane
is behind us it's a rock and a hard
place sure it'll burn i've set all the
fuel safety options to off
i hope so
sand for miles
do it
recording continues in silence for four
minutes until impact
flight was over an uninhabited area for
the crash preventing further casualties
it is believed that the resulting
explosion and dispersal of the spiders
that made up
scp-150619 is responsible for the
increased generation rate of scp-1506-1
okay now that we've got that absolute
nightmare out of the way this thankfully
concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and i'm sorry goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
allah treon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
jk
signor
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
scio dio demnaris
eric corbige
[Music]
james sabha
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you